[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
gabe sanchez breaks the [ __ ] internet
he sneaks into mar-a-lago
he talks to trump
he jots down trump's statements he
releases it on the internet and people
freak the [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
oh it's so funny it's so funny when
people don't understand what parody and
satire is it's hilarious it's [ __ ]
hilarious what's what's even better and
we've talked about this numerous times
on the show
is that
the point is is that it's it's hard to
parody or satire
someone like trump he is a parody of
himself
gabe sanchez decides yesterday
that it's probably a good idea
to write a statement about the joe rogan
uh interview where he says i didn't have
him on my show
you know we were thinking about what
trump would say about that
we figured trump probably would release
a statement so
and true gave sanchez style he broke the
internet
and it really didn't happen until this
morning
a lot of people fell for the statement
but
but some people got really butthurt
seth really is horrible he's [ __ ]
horrible at running a unfollow campaign
i would believe by the end of the day
that gabe sanchez probably has more
followers at the end of the day than he
had at the start of the day
and seth abrasion has like an account
that has almost a million
followers oh [ __ ] we need to find out
how many of those followers are real by
the way
no i told seth to block me too and of
course he did
seth blocked me because i called him out
on his [ __ ] he's talking about how
gabe sanchez isn't a fighter for
democracy and all you have to do seth
you [ __ ] idiot is run over to gabe's
twitter account
all you gotta do is run over there and
find out how much he is a fighter for
democracy every [ __ ] day
dumb [ __ ]
every day he's here monday through
friday the guy's even up two hours
before everyone else because he's on the
west coast you dummy
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
come on seth abrerson people are asking
who who's the one who attacked just just
go to uh go to go to my twitter or or
gabe's twitter or someone's twitter
you'll find the statements i had to
screenshot it because gabe um
with gabe's state the statement that he
made about gabe i went and [ __ ] told
him to shut the [ __ ] up um so i i went
over there and and and
i had to screenshot it because i knew he
blocked me
and he did well i told him i told him to
block me i told him to block me
oh my god why so serious seth we need a
uh we need a gif i guess
why so serious this is really
everyone knows that uh gabe sanchez puts
out these fake uh statements from trump
they know it
they know it daniel dale has uh
uh fact-checked him and he fact-checked
him this morning daniel fact checked in
this morning let's let's see if we can
find the uh
the daniel dale fact check here i want
to show you how daniel dale
uh always he spins you know he's a he's
a really he's a serious fact checker
that daniel dale
i mean he's serious this is serious
stuff folks
he really makes sure that he's got some
serious [ __ ] here you got daniel dale
here
this this is a fake statement trump
didn't make
this quote-unquote satirist you're dumb
on the says that in his got in his god
damn profile and if you came and [ __ ]
paid attention for a half a second you
would understand that it's not a
satirist he is
one of the hardest working political
satirists out there
twitter man i like that twitter man
twitter man satirist twitter man likes
to do fake stuff sometimes
daniel obviously woke up this morning
didn't even clean the gunk out of his
eyes
and decided that what he would do is put
an x because this is what this is what
he does to gabe's statements he puts a
big x because you know you can go you
know when you when you screenshot on an
iphone you can you can you know you can
use your finger to draw over it so he
puts a big x
to let to let everyone know
the fact
that this is a fake statement this is
fake everyone
it's fake
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock
yeah it's it tricks some people and it's
not because it's not because
that it's made for trickery it's so easy
when donald trump is such a [ __ ]
chucklehead and that's the whole point
of the statement you dummies
is to point out how much of a [ __ ]
chucklehead this guy is
i'm gonna we got a lot of [ __ ] video
to get to today in the shitless roundup
in the shitless roundup we got a lot of
[ __ ] to get to but i'm going to defend
my [ __ ] executive producer my co-host
here
in the first in the first rant here
because i believe it's important
here for you guys especially the
listeners out there
to understand why parody and satire so
[ __ ] important because that's kind of
the conversation that's happening
in seth's thread right he's like oh
people are like oh there's no time to
joke you can't joke about these things
he was making a joke
about joe rogan
saying out loud that he did not want to
help donald trump and he wouldn't have
him on his [ __ ] show
we're not talking about how donald trump
[ __ ] overturned the government we
didn't make jokes you serious folks
about the violence on january 6 that he
knew was gonna happen
by the way we're gonna have a new
hearing next week on tuesday we have one
announce but i think there's gonna be
more than one hearing next week
so stay tuned to the midas touch network
because next tuesday there's a hearing
so be looking for that link probably
later this afternoon
of that hearing
live coverage
if you want to if you want to get
serious seth come over and join us there
dummy
[ __ ] idiot
seth abrerson
i know i don't believe that his
following
is all real i i think it's probably fake
if this guy is attacking
is attacking a political satirist
it says taco connoisseur on his on his
on his twitter description
and and seth abrasion is really upset
that that a taco connoisseur and a
satirist isn't more serious
you [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] bonehead yeah
steve says seth needs a pardon blanket
he really does need a pardon blanket
that's the other thing too is if he
would have just spent i don't know two
or three minutes
like looking up who gabe sanchez was
like his videos go to his instagram go
to his tic tac it wouldn't it would not
have taken seth longer than three or
four minutes to realize oh
oh i get it this guy this guy i get it
i tell you what happened
seth is [ __ ] upset he's pissed off
seth abrasion is pissed off that he got
fooled
he really did believe
that donald trump said that [ __ ]
which is not not crazy honestly it's not
cra even if you fell for it out there
that's not it's not unbelievable that's
the [ __ ] point of the statement the
point is is that it is [ __ ] trump would
say
and yeah yeah yeah it you know it's
you know they call the dangerous we made
it we he made a [ __ ] statement
and he put out a statement on twitter
that appeared to be trump talking about
joe rogan
if you're
any kind of [ __ ]
got a brain in your skull you understand
that joe rogan is not a serious person
that's part of the problem is that joe
rogan is taken so seriously
and maybe that's what seth is upset
about
is that people who things that maybe
shouldn't be taken so seriously are
taken seriously like this statement that
gabe put out
which is obviously fake all you had to
do was go over the true social
and it's gabe's problem i guess that
seth doesn't have a true social account
to go check
i don't know
the best part is everyone is defending
gay beer
no one's defending seth i mean there's a
few people like oh it tricked me too
like get the [ __ ] out of here if this
tricked you
it only speaks to the [ __ ] danger
that donald trump is to our democracy
not the statement itself the fake
statement you dummies
the [ __ ] out of here need to learn they
need to learn what satire and humor and
parody is
and then maybe then maybe they'll have a
better opportunity
um to
mount an unfollow campaign i'm dead
serious this morning seth abrerson i'm
going to show it to you here
let me go to um
let she uh he's mounting an unfollow
campaign of of our co-host gabe sanchez
i'm not [ __ ] you
this guy is
he's out of his [ __ ] mind um here's
here's the tweet that i put up
because i definitely will defend gabe
sanchez
for sure especially when it comes to his
parody and satire uh seth iverson says
so cons is so concerned he's so
concerned with saving democracy that he
spends time attacking one of the hardest
working political satires fighting every
[ __ ] day for that same democracy set
claims he's serious about get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] follow at i
am gabe sanchez here's his i knew he was
going to block me
so i so i screen so i screen grabbed his
his tweets
i screen grabbed it
and you got to remember safe and i can't
go to his account now on
because he blocked me
i can't i mean i go there and it'll say
you're blocked you know what i mean but
he's got over he's got almost a million
followers so this is supposedly a really
big account by seth here
which is kind of [ __ ] ridiculous that
this guy who's got
900 some odd thousand followers are
recommending that he blocks
someone who works his ass off every
[ __ ] day to help save our democracy
regardless of what he uses seth parody
or satire otherwise you dumb
[ __ ]
i said he says says anyone who creates
fake documents it's it's not a fake
document it's not a fake it's a spoof of
a truth social you [ __ ] idiot if
anyone takes any of that [ __ ] that
happens over on true social seriously
you are the one who is fooled
anyone who creates fake documents
related to a certain former president he
can't even say trump's name here has a
means of getting clicks and spreading
disinformation not identified as such is
a danger get the [ __ ] out of here so
if you mark all your parody and satire
parody and satire it's no longer parody
and satire folks that is how it works
the whole point of parody and satire is
to make you make you feel
as it that go look up the goddamn
definition of satire
seth i thought you were an author go
look it up
get your dust your [ __ ] dictionary
off
uh spreading disinformation not
identified is a danger this state i'm
going to show you the statement here
we're going to read it to those of us
who are ardently trying to protect
democracy
he calls gabe not an ally folks
not an ally are you are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
me
everyone knows gabe sanchez his internet
persona
and let me tell you something folks
the same person he is on this show is
the same person he is off this show
what you see is gabe sanchez it's not a
[ __ ] act he is a [ __ ] ally seth
aberson and how how [ __ ] scummy is it
for someone who has such a big account
to punch down
especially when it's clearly satire and
parody
it was not tweeted from a real account
and by the way seth davidson i tweeted
the same [ __ ] picture from my goddamn
podcast account so come attack me
do it
[ __ ]
um here's the uh
here's the he made a thread by the way
he made a thread
seth averson was so butthurt that gabe
tricked him with this and this is the
folks because deborah messings in the
goddamn news too
over the same stupid [ __ ]
i was saying this yesterday you dumb
[ __ ] out there that are
attacking each other and going after
each other and not on the same team of
democracy are what is going to cause us
to lose
in december
excuse me
in the midterm november
in december we'll be crying in our milk
because we lost
because you don't want to give to
democrats you don't want to support
democrats because everything's democrats
fault because i didn't get i voted for
democrats and i didn't get everything i
wanted get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous
and this is more of that same [ __ ] that
i've been talking about
this is it right here this is it if he
if seth abrerson had any kind of [ __ ]
balls he would have went to gabe
sanchez's account and he would have
known that gabe sanchez is a [ __ ]
ally
and that game sanchez gabe sanchez is
one of the hardest working political
satirists that there is
the [ __ ] out of here with the every
[ __ ] day he's right here with me
five days a week
two hours a day
he's up early to get the show ready you
dumb [ __ ]
he continues on ps this man identifies
himself as a satirist
seth is now identi identity shaming
[Laughter]
but he celebrates when the fake
documents he creates yes that's the
whole point he even gabe even has in his
[ __ ] profile if you go look at him on
twitter and we will here in a second he
even even says he's been fact checked
and that's what he's talking about
that's what's talking about here so seth
clearly went to his account
he continues which aren't themselves
any ev
evident way linked to him
his feed or some sort of parody attempt
go viral so that changes what he's doing
considerably counts like this make me
sick
if if seth abrerson had any kind of
sense of humor which he clearly doesn't
he clearly has no sense of humor at all
like not even at all
if you had any kind of sense of humor he
would understand
the language that gabe sanchez is trying
to speak here
did you guys see the uh don jr uh gabe
sanchez video we're gonna watch that
today i wonder if seth i wonder if seth
thinks that [ __ ] is real
such a [ __ ] bonehead
what a [ __ ] bonehead and this is what
i'm talking about folks this is what i'm
talking about
seth abrerson this morning decides that
it's a good idea to attack
one of the hardest working political
satirists on his side and aiming for the
same things he's aiming for one of the
most pro-democracy satirists
that are out there right now and one of
the hardest working
one of the hardest working
there's a lot of things right now that
are ticking on behind the scenes here
and no one's seeing
and seth if he knew anything maybe maybe
he would just ask and we would tell him
and i'm not saying i i would love to
have seth on the show to give him a
piece of my [ __ ] mind
for sure
so seth abrasion
i'm gonna retweet this so it's at the
top of the feed boom
there you go go go um again he's got me
blocked see
look here
oh i wish i had some sound effects oh
i'm blocked uh gabe sanchez will be
joining us here in about 10 minutes and
we're going to go through the tweety
tweets and the journey trends but we'll
do our best we'll do our best to defend
him
from the scary unserious set person oh
when i found this out this morning gabe
gabe was actually laughing about it seth
uh he wasn't upset that you um
that you mounted an unfollow campaign i
was actually like dude you're gonna have
more [ __ ] followers by the end of
this because people are gonna go to your
[ __ ] profile
and they're gonna be like oh well this
is funny as [ __ ]
and they're gonna follow you
what a [ __ ] bonehead trying trying to
get people to unfollow gabe sanchez
and here he is gonna get gabe sanchez
more followers
gonna get him more followers by the end
of the day so here's the thing
here's the thing
if you like comedy if you like political
satire if you like what gabe does here
on the show make sure today to go give
support and make sure that we can get
gabe as many followers as we possibly
can on twitter so do not if you have a
twitter account go over to twitter
make sure make sure
that you go boost gabe sanchez today
and the ability of gabe sanchez to use
his talent as a satirist
to parody donald trump and make people
believe that donald trump thinks ron
desantis is president
because i'm going to wait to read this
the this statement that he put out i
actually may make gabe read the
statement
um that he put out and just just it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] what a loser
we have a lot of news today by the way
not just not just that gabe sanchez
broke the internet there is a lot of
news today there is a lot of news um but
some of the news we have is lindsey
graham we we
we uh had that at breaking at the end of
the day um the the ultra maga rooftop
shooter in highland park
uh illinois has been charged with seven
counts of murder
um a sad story in that same saga where
a child uh was found wandering around
downtown after the parade and they
couldn't find the parents come to find
out now the parents
had been murdered by the ultra maga
rooftop shooter
at the parade which is uh um very
disheartening
um we have um laura ingraham and tucker
carlson blaming two different two
different things
uh the ultra maga rooftop shooter
in highland park illinois
and
tucker carlson is blaming it on women of
course he is
and laura ingram is blaming it on pot
reefer madness reefer madness so we're
gonna go do that we also have what a
what appears to be a marjorie taylor
green video put out by patriot takes
this morning
uh
and it seems clear that she is trying to
make sure that there's more mass
shootings by claiming that the uh the
maga ultra maga rooftop shooting
in highland park illinois was a false
flag so she's encouraging more
rooftop shootings ron desantis is in the
news as well
also boris johnson and tim allen hmm
we have pat sipoloni
um is
may or may not testify the pressure is
ratcheted up it seems like
it could um get to where pat sipoloni
may have to he may just have to sit in
front of january 6 hearings
which brings me to a piece of news that
everyone should know let's see if i can
bring the tweet up here from the january
6
uh select committee
and they announced yesterday that they
are going to have
a a day 7 hearing
um and it's
unclear at this point we're trying to
get to the bottom of it uh it's an
earlier hearing
than um the last week last week's art of
the week before were uh
we're afternoon hearings these hearings
here are if i can find the [ __ ] tweet
um let's just go to the midas media
network tweet now the minus touch
network you know we're going to be
uh covering that
that story
live uh it will be let me pull this up
here again
oh no no wonder
no wonder
there we go i was on the wrong tab
i was wondering why it wasn't coming up
up the the midas touch network here new
the next january 6 committee hearing
will be tuesday july 12th
at 10 a.m eastern so that's next tuesday
on july 12th uh the actual hearing will
start at 10 but we will start our
coverage on the midas touch network
at 9 00 a.m you know we do an hour of
commentary before we will if there is a
break which there is bound to be we will
do commentary during the break and then
commentary after the actual hearing
uh which the likes with the midas
the midas network personalities we we
have
texas paul michael cohen every once in a
while david bender we have uh we have
the mizellas brothers from the midas
touch podcast now we have
michael popock and karen mcnippolo from
legal af that join us every once in a
while uh last we
we had ron reagan join us for for one of
the hearings maybe we can get ron reagan
back um i'll i'll
send a note out to see if we can get ron
reagan back everyone loved ron's
coverage
uh that one that hearing of that day so
we're gonna put together some panel for
you jessica denson's another one the
trump nda killer that we have on um and
uh lee mcgowan politics girl she's
joined us for a few of them so tune in
tune in on july
12th next tuesday
but tune in at 9 00 a.m eastern and
don't miss the hours worth of coverage
before for the commentary on the midas
touch network go over to youtube
follow midas touch there uh also
because you know we air every single
weekday
on youtube twitter twitch so also follow
us
while you're over there
on the tubes of you follow the tony
michaels podcast it's important
because you know we broadcast every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch and we also simulcast from the
midas touch facebook page so catch us
over there
on the midas touch network uh also
download us every single day seven days
a week we have a download
on apple spotify google your favorite
directory out there
every single show all two hours every
single day monday through friday we post
on all the directories and then on
saturday we have a best of show that we
post and on sundays we post bonehead of
the week
and boy we're at hump day
so bonehead's coming up pretty quick
here so you better go follow at tony
michael's pod and also go follow at i am
gabe sanchez today make a big push
make a big push today for gabe sanchez
don't disappoint
make sure seth abrerson's little
unfollow campaign shits the bed
oh
what a what a [ __ ]
what a wimp
like i said if he just went to gabe's
profile if he just paid attention for a
half a second he would understand that
gabe sanchez is the hardest working
political satirist this side of the
internet
this side of the internet
one of the hardest working there are
some good satirists
the good liars are good satirists walter
matherson is good as a good great
satirist
uh
jordan clapper is a good satirist but
gabe sanchez has a little bit more of a
seasoning on his satire
and you guys know it well you guys know
it well
so here is a bit of it in the break
we're gonna go to a break and we'll come
right back
with the [ __ ] list roundup
but maybe maybe seth would like to go
donate
to the trump fund
stick around don't go anywhere
we'll be right back after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots
what would you do if there is a trump
supporter right in front of you crying
in pain because they have to live under
communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
see tony michaels podcast the unserious
political commentary show
so unserious
oh people who don't understand comedy
are funny it's funny it's funny people
who don't understand comedy it really is
it really is
it's hilarious i thought it was funny
today when seth decided it was it was a
good idea to attack a small account on
twitter with his with his huge following
and really to probably probably break
the terms of service i would imagine i
mean i i would imagine you know mounting
an unfollow campaign from a verified
account is probably it probably breaks
the terms of service and really i think
they should probably take his [ __ ]
blue check away [ __ ] him
i want to thank um
marge's
midas margie here
and she says please
repost all the what was that videos on
the pod page
let's get what was that trending that
that is a great idea
mind is margie uh
joining us now
joining us now
is the person as a result
of an unfollow campaign
[Laughter]
what a phone head this working guy
no no i'm talking about seth not not
gabe right right right right right yeah
so
minus margie here has a great idea she
thinks we should all go repost what was
that so let's do this let's make sure
make sure that all those videos
do we have a thread main maybe we should
make a thread of them uh because i think
mine is kind of thread but we can make
it through it because i think mine is
touch post those on their account i
believe yeah these are on youtube so go
ahead and go and we also post them on
our youtube
after they're posted uh but there's a
what was that uh playlist on our youtube
channel so don't forget to come follow
our youtube channel you'll find the what
was that playlist uh there um and and
they're on twitter as well so go and be
spreading the links around and spread
the videos around that's a great idea uh
mind is margie we really appreciate um
all that uh and we have uh christina
also thank you for the uh super chat
it's absolutely insane man oh man you
know so
cause we had joked about it before it
went out and right well we we got the i
we got the because we were in a meeting
yesterday because the big things that
we're working on behind the scenes
bigger bigger than even this show big
things we're working on behind the
scenes and we we were in a meeting with
each other we were working on some
design and stuff of what we wanted uh we
we actually worked all through the
weekend on you know how to brand some
things and how to make this happen this
hopefully this big project that comes to
fruition that you guys can see
um but so we're we're working hard
and i brought up i said did you see that
joe rogan
said because you hadn't seen it yet i
was like have you seen it yeah yeah
rogan
said that trump he didn't want him on
the show
and then we kind of back and forth you
like i'm like you should do a statement
and you're like yeah yeah joe rogan and
then and that's how it happened that's
how it happened yeah and um and we even
said we even joke let's break the
internet like right yeah you sent me a
gif that was from pinky in the brain
yeah yeah yeah yeah i did i think i said
it said what what do we do tonight brain
break the internet
um so but but i mean it's all in good
fun it's all in good laughs and we've
talked about this before how it's it's
not easy to parody these people
sometimes right and and even like trump
when you're writing these statements
like you were sending it to me to to
re-read like what you had and i'm like
yeah um maybe maybe it should not have
that in there because it sounds dumber
when you don't put that here's the thing
i haven't done one in
the last time i did one was maybe in
february or march
uh when i was last fact checked by oh
really yeah it's like daniel's day i i
know i showed everyone
yeah yeah so the first one i did two
this this year uh one was in january i
got fact checked by reuters in usa today
and whoever else
and then uh the second one happened a
month later in february and this is and
then it was the last one where
um uh daniel dale fact check me again
here's the funny thing i did not change
anything in the what i wrote in the
tweet except for the name the last time
i said trump doesn't seem happy with
mike pence right now
wait wait wait wait wait see you i
didn't i didn't even know that yeah you
actually see you actually tweeted the
same here i'll find it i'll find it
the same [ __ ] the same thing and if you
look at daniel pale you'll find him
write something about the same he's like
big x it's funny because he did the last
one too so hold on right right the red x
is is uh classic daniel yeah yeah i've
got i'm i'm good i'm figuring out my
response right now but yeah to be honest
to be honest daniel dale is as dumb as
this is that he's spending time fact
checking this statement which is clearly
not a not a real one because all she'd
have to do all the person have to do is
go over to true social if you could
stand it for two seconds and go to
donald trump's account over there pan
down and realize that it's not real
right it's he doesn't delete and trump
doesn't delete anything so it wouldn't
it wouldn't get deleted even if you
could make that claim right what i what
i find funny
is so i just sent you the link for the
other one
uh what i find funny is that um
uh
seth is
he and i'm not telling anyone to do this
uh but he by using his account which is
what nearly a million people to block me
well it's supposedly a million people i
don't know
how many it's real i mean there are a
surprising number you know here look
full context i did not know what was
going to happen all right the last post
that i've done it has been like a couple
thousand likes on there and it gets
picked up by somebody
uh
what happens is a big account falls yeah
big account falls for it they spread it
that's the whole well
here's the here's the other thing too is
it spreads on to instagram and it goes
on to facebook and that's where
i then get contacted by someone to say
hey
do you know who made this
and then it gets written up and i give a
little quote or something like that
and
so
in the past they've been like a thousand
twelve hundred three thousand two
thousand whatever it might be
this one blew up overnight i mean we
went to i was you mean this last one
that we did this last one about joe
rogan and i figured it would because it
had joe rogan in it right and the other
thing too is is ron desantis worked his
way in
and and you know the idea that that
trump thinks ron desantis is president
number one is kind of laughable i i
don't
i i that's really the obvious parody of
it right yeah yeah like that last
statement about how ron desantis is a is
the president or would make obviously
it's alluding to the fact that that ron
desantis would make a second-rate
president he's trying to run for
president there's that dynamic but
everyone's like does he think ron
desantis is president and of course they
fell for it a little bit but that's the
question but that's the parody of it
that's the obvious you know they're like
market is parody market is that like
then it's not satire right and that's
not parody if i tell you beforehand
full discretion warning this is a parody
then you'd be like uh okay
right like i don't know maybe you'd
share it maybe like oh this is funny
look it'll come it'll go over like a wet
fart in a white thong it won't go over
the other the other thing too is like
the the statements that i've made in the
past have all been about incredibly
trivial topics right i don't want to use
it to belittle someone right you know an
actual person right i'm not going to do
it against anyone that's in the january
6 hearings like cassidy or anyone like
that like i feel like he's gonna do
enough damage on his own the times in
which i actually make these is about
mike pence at the giving a speech at the
federal society talking about how
january 6 was an insurrection or that
you know donald trump was at fault or
whatever
the one before that was about how he was
going to have a january 6th uh
conference
on january 6 at mar-a-lago
and then people were like oh you
shouldn't do that and then he
rescheduled it for some later date and i
made a joke that it was because he was
charging don jr to rent the venue to
plan his wedding which like yes i know
this could be a reality because it's
trump but also if you read it there are
certain hints along the way to be like
oh this is this is insane this is crazy
you know i don't know
yet again we live in a reality where we
do have to question like is this real
did he really say that i mean i guess he
could have said that
but it's not like you're hiding it's not
like you're hiding it though we're not
hiding
it's not like like we come on the show
and we talk about them like every time
it's happened we've come on here and
we've talked about how you tricked
people and even people who got tricked
were in the comments like oh my god you
tricked me it's funny that's the whole
point is to is to use the idea that
trump is so stupid and so petty that he
would make a statement like this that it
tricks you that's the [ __ ] funny part
that it tricks you that's the whole
point the whole point of the satire i
mean uh the two other great satirists
the good liars and and and walter they
trick people into thinking and that's
the funny part that's right [ __ ]
that's the satire of it uh mj says we
love you dirty sanchez which um
don't get the hashtag dirty sanchez
trending please please do not get the
ass jack hashtag dirty sanchez waiting
please all right she says [ __ ] seth and
then yeah oh you know i mean like look
again i don't know who this seth guy is
i've seen him like once um
because of something else he blew up on
someone about and took credit for
uh and then got called out for
but i don't know this guy i've never met
this guy i've never spoken to this guy
wait wait wait he's done this [ __ ]
before
yeah he took i don't know well he it was
him you he was he took some oh yeah yeah
he took a video yeah right right and
actually was 50 shades 50 shades exactly
yeah yeah and he had he just i just
retweeted uh that thread to give people
comments i think he had i think he had
to apologize or something that's what i
read exactly yeah yeah so he was like i
didn't steal anything you took it you
know it was a whole thing there's a
thread you could read it i retweeted it
but
each of these things that i've done
have been super trivial they're not
crazy important things like trump
announcing he's gonna [ __ ] you know
invade this country or do this or do
that they're all about the dumbest [ __ ]
possible right that's the that's where
the joke is here people are getting mad
at the fact that like well it's not
labeled as satire it's not labeled as
purity
it's it's it's a joke and now people are
gonna believe it like okay cool but i'm
not making you believe that he's doing
something that's like malicious this is
him talking about how some guy
said
uh it was wrong to overturn the election
and then he got upset about it
right he's not it's not like the guy he
the guy he encouraged in the go hang on
right exactly it's not like these
statements are even making the trying
push of course this one is from february
right right and that was the second one
that went uh that went viral
like is this the last one that you
actually
that might have been the last one that i
did uh and i was like no okay
uh and we talked about this one on the
show i believe right yeah we talked
about both of them on the show the one
in january and the one in february
because the one in january
was about uh uh having to reschedule the
very
uh
poorly
thought about
conference that he was gonna do
tomorrowlag which was like uh that's a
real bad taste to host a conference on
january 6th one year after the
insurrection but then again you know the
guy can't really read let alone read the
room so um
but yeah again these are all they're all
super trivial it's about the dumbest
[ __ ] possible this one the one that just
happened is about joe rogan saying how
he's not a trump supporter and he's not
going to have him on the show despite
being asked several times
and so this post
was just calling attention to that
and then i do want to point out here i
do want to point out here because
because people know that you do this
right people know that you do this it is
you have to go through a little extra
hurdles to to actually trick people to
for the satire right for the [ __ ] right
right right for the punch line the punch
line is that it's fake that's the punch
line right
so
you have to go through some extra links
here which this one appears to be
different than the last one
it appears that you are doing it on dark
mode and it appears to be
an actual screenshot of a
donald trump truth social post right
um but i want you to read this statement
here because
uh for everyone because yeah you know it
is the subject it is the the topic of
today
in seth abramson's mind of why it's
important for him to be saving our
democracy here so let's read this let's
go ahead and read the statement yeah
sure
hearing that lion joe rogan doesn't want
me on his podcast he said he was asked
more than once to have me on
lies
he asked me many times but i said no
he would be lucky to have america's
greatest president as a guest it would
be a record setting and a smart business
move for spotify
lion joe would rather have a second-rate
president like gutless ron desantis on
his low-rated show
you know the most disappointing thing
about this whole
situation here that we have was that
seth could have used his account to get
gutless ron
like he literally could have got his he
could have used his platform to get
gutless ron
trending hashtag gutless ron
which would have been the aim of our
democracy seth and fighting for our
democracy but you chose instead
instead to attack
to attack the great political satirist
that gabe sanchez is
instead of furthering the democracy by
getting gutless ron trending you pieces
the people
so people like uh seth who again i've
never met i never talked to uh i don't i
don't really know who he is but he seems
to have an issue with me um you know
just now somebody i i can't see his i
can't see his account because he blocked
me but
um somebody
said his account says proof in the
banner or something like that he's got
something that's called proof
right like
uh
well here's here's here's the thing
here's the thing here's the thing
i actually on our pod account seth
didn't do his research heavily enough
here because he obviously is not good at
research he didn't block the pot account
[Laughter]
he did he decided that it was you know a
good idea to attack the co-host of a
show and not block the account that he's
a host i mean honestly i could give two
shits
like i found it funny i okay this is
this is my kind of quick background here
i woke up two hours ago
and
uh because i'm on the west coast so it
was like 7 45
uh and i started getting met like i
started bing bing bing like i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on
and
i was getting messages from you and
other people and like uh dms from people
that were like oh set's going after you
uh and i was like what the [ __ ] is what
who who who i don't even know who this
is
so
i get all these messages
and my
just instinctual response is to laugh
because i saw this again
keep in mind that what he's doing right
now
is he is violating twitter's targeted
harassment policy
he has told his
how many other people i can't see his
account
944
944 000 people he's telling them to
block me which one i think is funny that
he was triggered that much
two he is violating twitter's uh
targeted harassment because he's he's
he is calling uh to action
uh people
to block me
here's here's the here's the tweet here
right
uh this is the actual tweet again he
didn't
he he blocked me blocked you because i
told him to block me i said you [ __ ]
block me too you dummy um so he blocked
me but he again he didn't he didn't
click on our profiles long enough to see
that we have a podcast and we have a
podcast and even the podcast shared a
photo last night yeah we did well
because we were trying to figure out a
way that people would buy into it so you
shared the dark um
the
the the dark screen version
i
did the normal screen version so that
way there was two out there so it would
kind of you know give it some validity
so it would have some legs and it did
and that's why seth's mad sass mad sass
mad because people want to laugh people
want to have some humor
and most people who who fell for it were
like oh that's so funny that i fell for
it it trump is so stupid and he puts out
such dumb [ __ ] statements that i can
believe that this is real if if joe
biden released a statement like this no
one would believe that it's real no one
if barack obama released a statement
like this no one would believe that it's
real no one no even if joe rogan even if
joe rogan released a statement like this
talking about how he didn't let donald
trump on his podcast no one would
believe the statement they would believe
the interview that you watching did you
see right right yeah yeah but they
wouldn't believe the statement if he
released a statement like on his twitter
they wouldn't believe it because it's
not
it's
so
again i'm just saying
this tweet right here violates
the twitter targeted harassment policy
just saying his tweets
he is uh trying to
command an army of 944
000 people to block me
which you know what you do what you
count what you want to do with your
account you know it's been funny to
follow along the thread because i can
see other people that have like i'm
tagged in it so i'm getting
notifications of people right you just
can't see the original the funny thing
is
that
most if not all of the messages i've
seen so far
have been somebody laughing at seth that
he would take the time
to do this i even see i didn't even know
this the second one whatever oh this is
the second this is this is great this is
the best part
so so then the other part of it is uh
is
is that
he
you know he's just he's just completely
upset about this fact and so he's like
come on this just
he's like he's [ __ ]
breaking down
i don't know it's just i find it
laughable i find it funny i don't really
care because again i don't know who seth
is and i don't know how he bought his
way onto new york times bestseller list
that is true it it probably is difficult
to scrape up enough cash to buy yourself
onto the so good which is which by the
way i just want people to know like you
know some people can legitimately get on
the new york times bestseller list and a
lot of people uh dinesh d'souza is
another is one of them
uh don jr don jr you can you can buy
your way on those lists by the way
because you just you just buy you just
bulk buy books right and then that's how
you get on the list so yeah i woke up
and i laughed i found this funny
here's here's seth's reply because this
is the best part about the whole thing
because obviously he's so upset he had
to tweet twice not just attack you and
attack your account he had to he had
this is hilarious
ps
he starts off ps this man identifies
himself as a satirist so he's identity
shaming number one
all right whatever and then he says but
he celebrates when they uh when the fake
docs he creates which aren't themselves
in any evident way linked to him
his feed
what do you mean you're posting it on
your twitter it's not like you're
[ __ ] posting on a sock puppet account
and then pulling it over we'll hear it
dumb the what does the first tweet say
can you scroll up
anyone who creates fake documents
related to a certain former president
as a means of getting clicks and
spreading disinformation not identified
as such
is a danger
i mean you're a danger gabe yeah got it
okay all right cool now scroll down on
the second one now what i find funny
about this is the fact that he says i
celebrate when the document when the
fake documents i create which aren't
themselves in any evident way linked to
him what like what
his feed or something parody attempts go
viral i haven't
okay
me celebrating
the most amount of celebration i do is
laughing at [ __ ] like this right right
and daniel dale because it's funny what
what has happened here is he posted this
right
he posted this two hours how long how
many people pose time to daniel dale
uh i don't know i'd have to i'd have to
go check i'll we'll check his time stamp
yeah yeah um but but uh so here's that
time stamp 9 22 a.m so keep that track
of that on my mind but um
this is the funny part is that he he
says to block you then he goes to your
account because he didn't go to your
account up here he went to your account
down here right he went to your account
and then realized oh and what he's
talking about the celebration part to me
is what he's saying the celebrations
the fake documents that he creates is
that you say you've been fact checked on
your like on your account yeah what's
what's funny is seth is actually taking
serious the twitter account that has the
picture the image at the top of you is
something and we can give people context
in a moment to what the [ __ ] that is and
i can even explain the video that's from
right but also you look at you look at
that you look at the banner
no one will take it seriously gabe
gabe it's in your profile it says taco
con and sewer like he's upset at a taco
like he doesn't he's he's clearly not
getting it right um but he says go viral
which honestly seth you're the one
spreading yeah he's he's pushing this
[ __ ] uh so that changes what he's doing
considerably accounts like this make him
makes him sick gabe makes him upset to
his tummy tum
he needs he needs he needs some chewable
pepto
anyway like i said i find it funny that
somebody would would then tell you know
his nearly 950 000 followers to go block
me again right violating violating
i didn't even i didn't even think
anything of it until someone was like oh
i think this is violating
twitter terms of service and i was like
oh [ __ ] and so that's just you know kind
of food for like but gabe is right gabe
is right what you should do is you if he
hasn't blocked you already because seth
likes to block people he's probably
spending a lot of his time this morning
blocking people defending gabe um if you
if you get a chance if you really do get
a chance the the hilarious part about
this whole statement is all the comments
down below incest thread like if you
want to know why gabe made this
statement and why it's so hilarious go
to seth's account go to this tweet and
read down the thread and you will
understand why that statement
is so hilarious is so hilarious gabe we
gotta i got a lot of video i want to
show you yeah yeah let's get let's get
to it i got a lot of views yeah so let's
let's do this let's start the countdown
and then let's go to the [ __ ] list
because i think we beat seth abrams and
enough this morning so let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast you have reached the
part of the show where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
of the day the [ __ ] list
roundup
and we have some non-parody video to
show you yeah
we have some non-video players if you
thought that was real hold on let me
tell you what's up well let me let me
say that this is
he he wants to he wants to talk about
stuff that's dangerous but here is a
patriot takes pulled this video i guess
this is on facebook is that what this is
yeah these are all from facebook this is
this is where i get i get the don junior
videos which by the way if anyone wants
to know i'm not actually friends with
don junior and i don't actually face
yeah yeah seth yeah seth he doesn't
spoiler alert spoiler that's not a real
phone call
i i'm not actually talking to don jr oh
my god in case anyone was worried and
thought i was and was worried about my
own well-being just know
it's a it's a fake it's not real ooh
seth that tricked him uh marjorie taylor
pedro takes puts this video out of her
whatever the hell this facebook thing is
is it a podcast or is
or is it just like a base facebook thing
i don't know it is it is a podcast uh
it's it's her podcast because remember
she i don't know like she has the other
she has the other one where she has the
set like she's got like the but here's
the thing again
she has she has a yeti microphone i know
that's which is pointless that's what i
have toward the camera right she's she
she totally is not speaking and that's
why the sound sucks right the sound
quality is horrible because she doesn't
know how to work this [ __ ] microphone
she has no clue she there's been times
where she hasn't pointed at her she
hasn't pointed away
and she clearly has not figured out her
road mic
um
because this is not the microphone that
she uses in the other studio right
and apparently that other studio is in
washington i don't know where this is at
i don't know anyways patriot takes uh it
says here marjorie taylor green suggests
two
four july four shootings
uh quote one in a rich white
neighborhood and the other at a
fireworks display
are false flags she's alluding to them
that they're false legs quote designed
to persuade republicans to go along with
more gun gun control honestly gabe in
this video it feels like to me
that old hoof foot green here is
encouraging more of these shootings it's
what it really sounds like to me
um
it because she knows what these
shootings are doing it's not it's not
about
uh tricking republicans into going along
gun reform it she's it's terrorizing
americans right it's making americans
terrified which is drawing up gun sales
gun manufacturers have been onto this
for over 20 years
when after columbine the nra and the gun
lobby were like whoa this mass shooting
stuff's going to be bad for business but
they
soon learned that mass shootings were
not bad for gun business it was good for
gun business because what they could do
is stupid [ __ ] like this and they could
spread the word that they're gonna come
get your gun so we're doing
oh my god the mass shooting happened so
now democrats are gonna take your guns
see they're gonna they're talking about
they're talking about taking your guns
because after mass shootings they're
like jesus christ when are we going to
do something about this for [ __ ] sake
and by do something boneheads here that
they're going to come to your house and
kick in your door and [ __ ] and these
these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes like marjorie
jay their greens encourage that which is
only encouraging more mass shootings
that's why we're in the situation that
we're in because they've been
perpetuating this [ __ ] for 20 years
because normalizing and radicalizing the
behavior you know right well and again
the gun lobby and the gun manufacturers
realized at some point about 20 years
ago that mass shootings were not bad for
business they were good for business so
man they like me i i would imagine in
some of the rooms and some of these gun
manufacturers
when they heard that someone from a
rooftop was using a rifle to murder
people they were like oh baby we're
going to sell a ton of ar-15s right this
weekend woohoo fourth of july
independence day i'm sure they're
somewhere in a in a really sick vile
gross room somewhere there were
[ __ ] cheering that this guy was
shooting from a rooftop because the nra
definitely did not did not say anything
but but tots and pairs but let's listen
to hoof foot green here encourage people
to commit [ __ ] shootings now
here's what i have to say i mean
two shootings on july 4th one in a rich
white neighborhood and the other at a
fireworks display
her tone there is really weird because
she's like oh looky here seems
convenient where a lot of people were
gathered someone comes with a rifle and
tries to shoot at people it's almost
like that's what the guns are designed
to do she's such a [ __ ] idiot
it's it's it's gross but listen
almost sounds like it's designed to
persuade republicans to go along with
more gun control i mean after all
remember we didn't see that happen at
all the pride parades in the month of
june but as soon as we hit
mega month as soon as we hit the month
that we're all celebrating loving our
country
we have shootings on july 4th i mean
hold up hold up hold up hold up hold up
yep yep she said it she said she said
she's saying basically that that it's
all false flags and it's a proof that
it's false flags because people didn't
come shoot gay people because definitely
a hundred percent people would want to
do that is what she's saying to me
that's what i'm [ __ ] hearing yeah i
mean like the fact that she would be
like oh it's pride month you know which
is like anyone with you know within
within that group lgbtq you know ia plus
like the the fact that she's like well
nobody went after in the pride paraders
pride month like one darn it that's very
yeah i know to like compare them be like
nobody talked about when these shootings
happened in june but all of a sudden
when it's white people month which is
what they're saying right they're trying
to claim
july as mega month white people month
that's what they're trying to do because
they were so triggered that june had
both juneteenth
and pride the fact that these people
who right now are at risk of having
their own rights taken away
by the supreme court when they come back
in session
she's saying that oh man you know it's
really important that nobody talked
about this [ __ ] that happened because
they're all gay people and it's like
whoa whoa
she's almost saying i'm look let's pump
the brakes here let's put a bet it
sounds like to me she's disappointed
that people didn't go shoot up at
certain parades here let's listen with
more gun control i mean after all
remember we didn't see that happen at
all the pride parades in the month of
june but as soon as we hit gosh darn it
we didn't see it happen in all the prize
parades in june gosh darn it boy that
would have been great listen to the end
here because it gets even it gets even
more disgusting
we have shootings on july 4th i mean
that's oh you know
that would sound like a conspiracy
theory right of course
but what's the definition of a right
wing there you go theory well by the way
it's the news that's just six months
early
it clearly clearly she thinks she's
funny this is kind of um
again seth abrasion if you're really
going to go after someone trying to be
funny that's not funny here's here's
your target dummy right this she's
trying to be funny with the whole
right wing conspiracy theories are just
the news six months early because i
think what she's trying to say here is
i'm telling you what's going to happen
in the future
and if you go back and get the tape here
here's what she says about pride parades
along with more gun control i mean after
all remember we didn't see that happen
at all the pride parades in the month of
june
[ __ ] [ __ ] i don't use that word a lot
why i have to use it a lot with these
[ __ ]
[ __ ] boxes but it is very appropriate i
think and i think the audience will
understand when i use that word when it
comes to marjorie taylor green holy [ __ ]
i mean basically encouraging basically
encouraging people oh gosh darn it we
didn't have any shootings that we had to
have a shooting at a at a at a white
knight in a white community we had a
shooting at a fourth of july patriotic
parade but not it and not at pride
parades gosh darn it that's almost what
it sounds like she's saying is it am i
getting this it sounds it's i mean
honestly to me it sounds like she's a
bit upset that you know the attention or
yeah possibly more gay people didn't get
shot up and talked about because
it's
it's just unfair it's so unfair that
that all of these white people are you
know who are trump supporters or [ __ ]
trumped up bigots or whatever they might
be all of a sudden are like hey i'm
going to take this gun and i'm going to
go you know shoot some people and so you
know we we've listened to what she said
from buffalo to uvalde to now where
she's like she's trying to prove that
it's everything but the gun right it's
the it's the person and where they're
from their background it's the fact that
uh the person is
uh taking ssris right it's like god
forbid this person cares about their
mental health and they want to take
medication to do that but now you're
trying to vilify the drugs to help them
make feel normal in an un otherwise
not normal society
then you're trying to push it further to
be like oh well the reason
nobody is talking about it and it's not
a big deal is because they're white
people
and
nobody talked about the gay people and
it's like
what the [ __ ] dude like you keep jumping
the mental gym the stretching you had to
do
to get to these mental gymnastics is is
scary and impressive at the same time
because
again this is the same person who was
saying oh you can't ask about my
vaccination status because that violates
my hipaa rights but in the same breath
you know as shitty of a person as it is
that the shooter was or is
saying you know what drugs what drugs
are they on where were they where were
they what what psych ward were they in
you know we're gonna we're gonna get to
that we're gonna get to that at the
mental gymnastics about the shooter
because the fact is is he was an ultra
manga rooftop shooter and they do not
want to talk about the gun or that he
was a trump supporter right so they
definitely talk about all kinds of other
[ __ ] on fox news but i do want to point
out something that you said about
marjorie taylor green and maga month
being white white people month
being white month white white supremacy
month
we've had this [ __ ] idiot i usually
don't show this guy's
videos but here is proof of what you're
talking about when you're talking about
this maga month being white supremacy
mother listen to these two little [ __ ]
here now i wanna i wanna i'm gonna give
people a clue um this this game with the
with the the
half-assed handlebar mustache here yeah
because he can't grow a beard he does
this
it's like if you took a bunch of uh
toothbrush bristles and you cut them off
and then you superglued them to your
face and you tried to wax them into
something that's more or less what that
is right he's like oh mega month oh yeah
[ __ ] mega month i love it i love good
magamond let's like
see what gabe's talking about here but
yeah this little [ __ ] this little [ __ ]
here
these two little shits would have their
asses kicked and oh
almost any kind any kind of
confrontation he got his ass kicked by
just words from a teenager well did you
see the video where he had a bullhorn
and he was he was calling women [ __ ]
and [ __ ] at a protest and they
outshouted his bullhorn that's how much
that's how much of a dumb buck this guy
is but listen to what these two little
shits say
um and they're and they're trying to
stoke
uh uh violence here is what they're
trying to do but listen what up bro here
fourth of july you know can't forget who
founded this country it was the white
the white settlers the the pilgrims the
the that's colonized they definitely
don't know who's who's yeah he's like
dude [ __ ] uh dude do you remember from
seventh grade uh what what's the word
was it was it it was christopher
columbus man uh yeah
1692
sailed the ocean blue oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah the [ __ ] idiots let's listen
also it's 14. isn't it 1492. was it yeah
it was 1492. sorry i got the rhyme wrong
i got the rhyme wrong it's okay you're
gonna knock on me yeah okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna reach out to seth abramson
and daniel dale and get them to fact
check this podcast right now definitely
need a fact check that that uh
at schoolhouse ryan to remember when
christopher columbus
when when christopher columbus falsely
founded america yeah okay fake news
colonizers you know i'm a proud
colonizer are you a pro colonizer yes
does he know that colonizer means that
you came here and stole the land from
the indigenous people does he know that
he's like yeah i'm so happy first person
so happy that there was in indigenous
people genocide
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
let's say that let's say that they were
a new uh branch of colonizers this guy's
talking about independence day two like
the like is he talking about the alien
movie like the movie with with uh
what are you saying what he's saying is
that they're gonna take over our country
and they're gonna right right they're
gonna rid because listen to what he said
they're gonna read us
of all the other non-colonizers is what
he's getting all the other non-white
people is what he's saying we're coming
for you zionists
the the the the new declare declaration
of independence from the globalists
coming soon you know the new uh the new
we're the new founding fathers that's
anti-semitism
we're the new
we're the new founding fathers so not
only does ethan schmidt can't he can't
[ __ ] handle a handle up a handlebar
mustache
he can't he can't smoke a cigarette he's
got to use a toothpick yeah cool but he
thinks he's the new thomas jefferson
this guy
this guy thinks he's thomas jefferson he
okay look he's the guy that if they were
to come over in 1492 and he was like
yeah
i'll i'll jump at that opportunity he
jumps on the boat and it takes you know
three to four months to get across i
don't even know if he would make it okay
honestly uh and also if he did make it
i'm pretty sure that he would be [ __ ]
axed right away because people like oh
[ __ ] look some person we can't trust is
trying to kill our people and steal our
land he would be the first person on the
front line to be like
done
there it is there it is you know
he's smoking the toothpick what a
[ __ ] you know we're out here saving
america is that even america or what the
[ __ ] is that empire is coming soon
yup
you know
celebrate white culture guys this july
there you go he couldn't even get like
the empire is coming back which empire
the royal british empire is that what
you're talking about no the thing is
people left um
to us to to found this this country you
know this land they left
the british royal family the the the
establishment that they had there and
they said we don't want that so we want
our own thing we're going to form our
own government
i don't know this guy is an idiot
uh it's
but also it's like is it
like was he trying to make a like a star
wars joke or like a reference there too
like he said independence day and then
instead of saying return of the jedi he
said or that or uh empire strikes back
he said
something be uh be aware of the empire
or be ready for the empire or something
i don't know
something's going on with my twitter
over here
did did did someone report me
[Music]
well that'll be that'll be hilarious i'm
i'm excited about that i don't know you
might want to pull up your uh your
twitter there so we can uh go through
some more of these i can't i can see the
pod account on mine no no it's not the
pod account it's my uh it's my account
oh
yeah i think i think i've i think i've
been i think i've been reported
oh [ __ ]
let's see
those oh okay so i'm on the pod account
now let's yeah
here we go hold on hold on hold on hold
on
let's go to let's go to uh let's see if
i'm i'm uh wait wait what the hell is
going on hold on
is your is your account well i got
logged out i got log wait hold on let me
let me see this no i'm good it's good
it's right here we'll just go from this
account here we'll just go from here
what a
i don't know i got log i got logged out
maybe twitter did something happen with
twitter did you really break the
internet because this was the graphic
this is the graphic that we put out this
morning i can still
i can still see him
breaks the internet and he might have
actually broke the internet hold on
now they said they see both accounts i
know i don't know okay somehow somehow i
got
oddly i also got just log i was also
just logged out of my web account yup me
too i think i think it must be a twitter
thing okay must be a twitter thing i was
like don't freak out don't forget so um
another video that i want to show you
because marjory taylor green is a really
a big fan of putin like a huge fan oh
yeah
she she i think she actually loves to
grab a cardboard cutout crotch of putin
more than she does trump um
but did you see this video of putin
talking about some nonsense uh being in
newsroom says watch on russian state tv
president putin stated that sweden and
finland are free to join nato because
their circumstances differ from ukraine
so in other words he's like yeah i can't
go and invade sweden and finland but the
reason why he claimed that he was going
to invade ukraine one of the reasons was
they were going to join nato which would
threaten russia and he says it in this
statement and i'm not going to play this
statement because it's in russian and
i'd have to repeat it the thing i want
to do is show everybody he looks like
[ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't he yeah he's
his eyes are sunken like it looks like
he's having a rough time because
remember he was supposed to take over
ukraine in a matter of 12 hours i mean
this is not and i almost thought that
this was a double at first
yeah man i i actually thought this was a
double at first i'm like whoa that
didn't even hardly look like putin
because he's still bloated and [ __ ]
right yeah what
because some people have surmised that
maybe he's getting some sort of medical
treatment that would do this uh you know
you think that he's he's ill with
something like he had some sort of
condition or cancer or whatever well i i
don't know but but uh there's there's
the like you said again the eye sockets
in uh manny just he looks like [ __ ]
[ __ ] he kind of looks like trump almost
i said
is it me or this [ __ ] look like
shite i mean he look i mean dude he
looks like shite holy [ __ ] um so there's
that and i i just wanted to show
everybody what putin's looking like
these days
uh
there was another video oh yes oh my god
talking about a gun reform have you seen
this video from um
the congresswoman from arizona her name
is uh uh debbie lasko
oh yeah what did she do what did she do
what did she did something earlier this
year and we had her
yeah there was something in the shower
something that we had her on the show
yeah
this is something that we had her on on
the show she did something because she's
a [ __ ] bonehead she was she on
bonehead of the week possibly i don't
know i don't know let me let me check
that doesn't sound familiar but it's
possible
but but but lasko here goes to the floor
and she's um she's talking against a gun
reform bill here
but listen to what this [ __ ] creepo
says about her grandchildren and what
she would do to them this is
this is the gun culture that is causing
people to [ __ ] go kill people they
don't know in crowds and [ __ ] and at
schools this is the kind of [ __ ] talk
this is the republican [ __ ] that is
perpetuating the gun violence in this
country listen to what this this
she is just a [ __ ] box listen to this
arizona is recognized for two minutes
thank you representative jordan i rise
in opposition first off thanking
representative jordan for anything
you get you clearly do not have good
marks right i mean just right there in
the very beginning when you think jim
jordan for anything yeah i don't have
clear good marks
let's go to h.r 2377.
i have five grandchildren
i would do anything anything to protect
my five grandchildren okay so she's a
grandmother she has five grandchildren
she would do anything anything to
protect those five grandchildren right
and i'm sure we have a lot of people in
the chat here that our parents
grandparents and they would do anything
absolutely anything
to protect their children or their
grandchildren listen
to where this [ __ ] psycho's mind goes
when she's talking about anything to
protect them it's [ __ ] weird gross
it's disturbing grandchildren including
as a last resort shooting them if i had
to to protect the lives of my
grandchildren
shooting them
yeah she's talking about murdering her
grandchildren here
on the floor of the united states house
of representatives
debbie lasko is talking about murdering
her five grandchildren
it's it is uh shocking and not shocking
at the same time
what the [ __ ] is going on
and people are are running around
wondering why the [ __ ] are people going
into schools and killing children why
are why are people showing up at grocery
stores and killing black people why are
people showing up at parades and
fireworks and shooting innocent people
why are they doing that right because
because their minds are where debbie
lasco is
that their first their first inclination
to protect their children
is to not only have a gun to protect
them but to actually kill their children
are their grandchildren
with that gun like
i can't even tell you
how people even manage to convince
themselves that they need high power
rifles to protect their family from
their enemies i i mean i don't know what
kind of enemies you have gabe but i
don't have the kind of enemies that i
would need a rifle to protect my fan i
just don't think i have those kind of
enemies i don't i don't think maybe but
i don't think so but she's going one
step towards the the abyss here yeah
and saying the gun is for me to kill
someone that i'm trying to protect
that's literally what she's saying like
what in the future can you can you
replay it
yeah yeah
yep we'll back it up here i want to
start with the part where she thanks
this scumbag jim i don't report sex
crimes jordan that's important from
arizona is recognized for two minutes
thank you representative jordan i rise
in opposition to h.r
2377
i have five grandchildren
i would do anything anything to protect
my five grandchildren including as a
last resort shooting them if i had to to
protect the lives of my grandchildren
what the [ __ ] does that even mean i
don't even know like i can't even like
so i guess maybe her idea is is like if
one of my five grandchildren get one of
the guns that isn't locked away and it's
loaded in my house and starts shooting
my other grandchildren maybe i'll go get
my high power rifle and start shooting
them i don't know what the [ __ ] she's
talking about here i'm i'm not in the
[ __ ] what it doesn't yeah i don't know i
mean like just when you just when you
think they can't go lower or they can't
jump to some uh
insane kind of thought process they go
oh you know what well the way to stop uh
you know like i will shoot my kids like
or my grandkids like what the like why
why are we even having this discussion
here's the thing you wouldn't even have
to create that hypothetical if you never
had the weapons accessible but also even
those high-powered weapons in your home
or even those high-powered weapons
available for you to purchase like one
how many guns do you have in your home
that that would be happening and two
maybe there's something before the
do i have to shoot my grandkids argument
and bring it back to maybe if the guns
weren't in the house or maybe these guns
weren't accessible or you know just
weren't available to the general public
that wouldn't be a problem right but
they jumped to say like well we can
never get rid of guns so we have to work
we have to live in a world where it's
like what happens if the guns then get
into baby's hands and the grandkids
start shooting up the place
and it's like well what do i do then and
it's like why are we even why are we
even getting they're [ __ ] off their
goddamn they're off the reservation
they're out of their they're out to
lunch they're [ __ ] lunatics it just
does not make any sense it doesn't make
sense just like it doesn't make any
sense how tucker carlson frames up why
the [ __ ] ultra maga rooftop shooter
went and shot up a bunch of innocent
people i think there's now seven dead i
think is the count um and the sad story
of the child that was walking around
downtown by itself and people online
trying to find their family only to find
out that the boat their parents were
killed in the shooting is absolutely uh
just tragic and to watch debbie lasko
and talk about shooting her own
grandchildren on the house floor this
isn't like she was making this comment
someone recorded it she intended this to
be on official record in our government
on the dallas floor that [ __ ]
psycho like she thought you know what
i've gotta i've got a real i got a real
stumper for these people i'm gonna write
this argument that talks about me
shooting my you know grandchild shooting
each other and me shooting my grandkids
because that's the only possible way out
of this crazy world we live in not get
rid of the guns not you know create a
more safe environment with people who
actually own guns
but you have to create this world where
it's like yeah the
they got the guns i don't know how they
got the guns but now the only way to
stop the kids with the guns is to shoot
them with my own guns it's like
well i gotta tell you one of my one of
my grandmothers she's gone now but um
she's been gone for several years she
was pretty tough like she did not she
was like a john wayne toilet paper
[ __ ] rough tough and didn't take
[ __ ] off nobody right yeah and she was
not she was not the kind of grandma like
you would go over and she'd bake cookies
and give you candy not that kind of
grandma she was roughed up but i don't
think she would ever be like i'm gonna
shoot this [ __ ] like i know like
what are you how in the [ __ ]
i don't i don't know it's just it's
insanity and the other insanity is the
not just the [ __ ] culture that
they're creating to for people to go do
this where marjorie taylor green is
disappointed that people didn't shoot up
a pride parade and debbie lasco
representative debbie lasco wants to
murder her grandchildren but here's
tucker carlson blaming women blaming
women
like seriously just blanket blaming
women for the shooting that happened in
highland park listen to this [ __ ] that
look at robert bobby cremo
would you sell a gun to that guy does he
seem like a nutcase of course he does so
why didn't anyone raise an alarm well
maybe because he didn't stand out maybe
because there are a lot of young men in
america who suddenly look and act a lot
like this guy it's not an attack it's
just true
like cremo they inhabit a solitary
fantasy world of social media porn and
video games they're high on
government-endorsed wheat smokes
jesus christ they're nominated by the
endless psychotropic drugs that are
handed out at every school in the
country by crackpots posing as
counselors
right and of course they're angry
they know that their lives will not be
better than their parents
they'll be worse that's all but
guaranteed they know that they're not
that stupid
and yet the authorities in their lives
mostly women never stops lecturing them
about their so-called privilege you're
male you're privileged imagine that try
to imagine an unhealthier unhappier life
than that
so a lot of young men in america are
going nuts are you surprised
and by the way a shockingly large number
of them have been prescribed
psychotropic drugs by their doctors
ssris or antidepressants and that would
include quite a few mass shooters
so is this is this the one with the
woman
he's talking about privileged white men
here which is kind of funny how this
privileged white dude is talking about
privileged white man plight yeah get the
[ __ ] out of here now we know that
they're blaming weed um here's another
bonehead
laura ingraham
listen to this [ __ ] listen to this
but instead of selling fear and division
wouldn't it be nice if we all began to
focus on solutions don't people want
solutions that's that's what people
actually been talking about you [ __ ]
idiot
what uh do these are these people that
[ __ ] dumb
are they that dumb let's listen since
they do
now on the mass shooting in illinois
indications are that robert cremo was a
regular pot user now everyone look at
him and to the untrained eye he looks
like a complete psychotic
he's a regular pot user now gabe i'll
have to admit i haven't smoked i've
drank a lot of alcohol in my life but i
haven't done a lot of i i haven't smoked
a lot of pot um you've actually made fun
of me um i think it was a while back we
were texting and i said something about
and you said the pot you said yeah the
pot i said you know someone doing the
pot you're like uh anyone who says doing
the pot
obviously oh okay boomer i think is what
you said or something like that yeah i
was like okay that's how that's how we
all talk about once we're having the pot
the pot the pot the wacky weed as it
might be referred to wacky tobaccy i
think it's what they call it right now
yeah yeah yeah well
i i'm not a i'm not a pot smoker but i i
sure as hell know that a regular quote
unquote a regular pot user
because at this point we all know how
marijuana works you smoke it or you eat
it you get high for a little while
and it's gone and then you to get high
again you have to do more pot right
ready yeah eating it right
yep yeah
[ __ ] you you know yeah go [ __ ] i'm i'm
on ses team now i'm on team yeah yeah
yeah
no no no i'm serious though
this is a situation where
someone
because i've known some potheads in my
life and the reason why potheads smoke
pot all day long is to stay high all day
long right yeah like pot doesn't the
high isn't like
you take the [ __ ] drug or you do the
drug whether you're eating it you're
smoking it whatever you're doing and
then it lasts for like 12 days or some
[ __ ] that's not how it works and by the
way
i've known a lot of potheads in my life
they not only i mean the best they could
do is try to roll over and lay down on
the couch once they're [ __ ] stoned to
the bone
let alone walk a mile and a half from
their [ __ ] house and climb a ladder
up on a rooftop like nope no regular
pothead is motivated after they smoke a
bunch of reaper reaper madness and go
climb a ladder up on a rooftop give me a
[ __ ] break no one believes that
garbage do they do they really believe
this
i think people do believe this people
who are just uneducated and listen to
this right uh but i mean like you know
marijuana is is used for all sorts of
things right whether it's thc or cbd
like there's different forms and and
different applications whether it's like
oh i need to make a cpd oil or i need
something to kind of
uh
you know uh create calm you know they're
just like all these different things and
they try to blame drugs right well maybe
we should look at other things right or
maybe we should look at why someone
might want to do that whether it's out
of their own kind of leisure or they're
like man this world's so [ __ ] up i
just kind of need to
step away and and sit on my couch
because here's the thing
never have i seen anyone it's like
harold and kumar
right they have that psa which they're
making fun of which is the two guys get
high
and then
uh he's like oh dude what are you doing
and he's like oh don't worry man and
he's holding his dad's shotgun right is
it oh don't worry and then it's like you
see that you know you hear the shotgun
go off and it's like don't be like them
don't smoke marijuana you know and
they're trying to they're making fun of
the whole um
uh you know nancy reagan just say no
don't do drugs this kind of the war on
drugs kind of thing
and that's how ridiculous this sounds to
be like oh yeah you smoked marijuana and
now
you want to go buy a gun and you want to
shoot up a a parade like the the
motivation when whenever i smoke
whenever i do you know uh what whatever
sort of drug i've never wanted to
in all of that time whether it's
it is marijuana or it's some other you
know um
uh
uh
you know psychoactive drug or whatever
it might be right like i've never said
hey
what i need to do right now
is i need to go buy a gun
and i need to use that gun
to shoot people right like even the most
is like if someone's like oh i'm
paranoid like you're apparently like i'm
not moving i'm not gonna i'm paranoid
i'm not gonna leave the couch i'm just
gonna say stay here
you know like i've had those moments
when i've been you know high with
friends and i've said something and then
it's like super you think it's super
quiet and everyone stops talking you're
like wait did i say too much should i
not have spoken then you don't want to
talk and then you do want to talk and
it's like this awkward moment that's the
most amount of anxiety or confusion or
just like me feeling like oh [ __ ] i
should not have had this is that is me
feeling like paranoid in that moment
like oh [ __ ] do people know i'm high
that's it i've never wanted to be like
oh you know what i'm going to climb this
ladder onto this roof
laying out for weeks right to go do this
boneheads
boneheads i'm still having trouble
logging into my i can't i can't log into
mine i can you know on my phone
yeah yeah i can get on my phone i can't
go online and i'm deep it's the deep
state i don't know i had to message a
couple people while we were chatting to
be like can people still see
this is the reason this is the reason
why our accounts [ __ ] up right this is
the reason right here
uh this this interview that was done
because this is this is the reason why
you did the statement yes we were we
were watching this video we were talking
about this video as we're having a
meeting
and um so let's play it here let's play
joe rogan uh talking about how he he's
had trump uh contact him several times
to be on the show but he's like [ __ ] you
right by the way i'm not a trump
supporter in any way shape or form i've
had the opportunity to have them on my
show more than once which i actually
believe joe rogan when he says he's not
a trump supporter like i actually
believe that
and the reason why i believe that is
because he did uh
now remember i don't think joe rogan
knows anything about politics he really
doesn't he's a [ __ ] idiot he has no
clue about politics he doesn't know
about government he really doesn't know
about any of that stuff and the reason
why is i i the reason why i say that is
because i've listened to [ __ ] he said
right and he just doesn't he knows a lot
about martial arts he knows a lot about
like uh mma fighting but he doesn't know
about politics or government so i do
believe him when he says that he's not a
trump supporter and i do believe him
when he says he's had trump on
contact um
to be on a show i 100 believe that um
and i believe him when he says he has
told him no because he hasn't been on
there
but listen now he frames it you need to
have him on my show more than once i've
said no every time i don't want to help
him i'm not interested in helping him
the the night is still young we'll see
if i have here's the thing and i
actually don't believe him when he says
i don't want to help him
because he does help him every single
day oh yeah he continues to help him
every single day by [ __ ] talking
stupid [ __ ] and spreading stupid [ __ ]
information having trump supporters on
his show spreading the nonsense right
like that's that's where i [ __ ] fall
short on joe rogan here saying oh he's
just like he's doing the whole i'm a
comedian i can't be held responsible
like i can't be held responsible for
having a bunch of trump supporters on my
show spewing the [ __ ] that trump would
want right now i do have to say that joe
rogan makes a good point here at the end
of why he doesn't have trump on his show
but i don't believe that trump that he
has trump doesn't have trump on the show
because he doesn't want to quote help
him because he is helping him by having
all these other chuckleheads on but
listen mom tonight is still young yeah i
think i'll have them on i think you'll
have them on really why do you think
that because you'll have putin on
and you're competitive as [ __ ] no
[Laughter]
i i think
ultimately
um i mean you had you've had a lot of
people that i think you might you may
otherwise be skeptical would i have a
good conversation which i think is your
metric you don't care about politics so
can i have a good conversation and i
think you you had uh like people people
like kanye on for example and you had a
great conversation with them i think you
i think uh yeah but kanye's an artist
like but kanye doing well or not doing
well doesn't change the course of our
country
so here's the point that he's gonna make
right about having trump on and having a
conversation with him and changing the
course of our country because i i
actually do think he's right here that
that the kind of oxygen that seth rogen
would give him could
could make changes and yeah listen to
the changes that he talks about here
yeah but you know
do you really
bear the responsibility of the course of
our country based on a conversation i
think you can
revitalize and rehabilitate someone's
image in a way that is pretty shocking
so have you seen have you seen the the
next part of that clip no do you have a
do you have a link there
um but that that so that there where
he's talking about revitalizing trump's
image um that is something that joe
rogan actually understands here he
understands he has the ability with his
audience to be able to um
to be able to
make his audience revitalize someone's
reputation
um through his the follow-up to this is
quite the
yeah i just sent you a link
so what show is this that he's on he's
on
uh whose podcast is this
who is this guy that he's talking to
uh
let's see joe rogan
so this is the follow up here let's
let's listen as you're looking that up
yeah
biden
shakes hands with people that aren't
even there when he gets off stage yeah i
think he's seeing ghosts yeah you see
him on jimmy kimmel the other day no
well he was just rambling i mean he's if
he was
anyone else
if he was a republican if that was
donald trump doing that
every
[ __ ] talk show would be screaming for
him to be off the air and i'm by the way
i'm not a trump supporter in any way
shape or form i've had the opportunity
to have him on my show more than once
i've said no every time so so the the
there's a follow-up here at the end is
that what you're saying yeah yeah okay
so that was the lead-in
here is the here's the part image
in a way that is pretty shocking look at
the way people look at alex jones now
because alex jones has been on my
podcast a few times yeah how do they
which direction the people that have
watched those podcasts think he's
hilarious
and they think that he definitely [ __ ]
up with that whole sandy hook thing
um yeah but definitely
yeah he's right more than he's wrong and
he's not an evil guy he's just a guy
who's
had some psychotic breaks in his life
he's got some genuine mental health
issues that he's addressed he's had some
serious bouts of alcoholism some serious
bouts of you know substance abuse and
they've contributed to some very poor
thinking
but
let's listen if you know the guy
if you know the guy so here here he is
and this is what he's talking about
because this is the dangerous [ __ ] this
is the dangerous magic that joe rogan
has right right like he has this
audience this big enough audience that
he actually can have someone like alex
jones on and it gives them a platform to
seem i don't know normal yeah right and
normal in a way that is mainstream
that and that's the [ __ ] problem that
that joe rogan has right and it's really
joe rogan's problem yeah you know it's
joe rogan's problem because he's he has
cultivated this audience that has
allowed him to have this manipulation
where he can have people on and
revitalize their reputation right not
only not only does joe rogan understand
this idea his guests that he has on
understand this idea why d and joe rogan
is yelling at the rooftops here the
reason why trump wants to come on in my
show
is to revitalize his image so listen to
that for a second listen to that fact
for a second if the fact really is that
joe rogan knows and trump knows that
that joe rogan won't have trump on
to revitalize his image
then that only speaks to the point
that trump needs to revitalize his image
and that's what he's trying to do
so badly that's what he that's what all
the [ __ ] true social posts are that's
what all these sycophants out there
lying and spreading lies and building
lies on top of lies on top of lies which
are gonna topple and crumble here yeah
um because it seems that donald trump is
gonna be indicted in georgia it it it
almost doesn't even look like there's
gonna be any wiggle room for some of
these other people to get out of
indictments there uh we're gonna see
this hearing on tuesday which only puts
kaylee mcinanny on the hot seat here um
she has went in and actually testified
in the hearing and i wouldn't be
surprised that if this deputy press
secretary that is the one reason why
they want her to testify is because
she's actually going to refute some of
the [ __ ] that kaylee mcaneney has
testified to under oath and under
deposition to the january 6 select
committee i would say that caitlyn
mcinerney if she is not a little
nervous about tuesday's hearing she
[ __ ] should be because she's also one
that is isn't she isn't she one that's
being that got a subpoena
from georgia um the georgia subpoena i
know it was city or just legal team
uh oh sorry who who did you ask was
godzillionaire kaylee mcinanny
i didn't see her name i just saw the
legal team like jenna ellis and all that
right right but she's given deposition
well i'm confusing kaylee macanadi and
jenna ellis i guess um you know one got
farted on by rudy giuliani the other one
may have just made just uh uh
had a drunken bout with him during the
election night i don't know because
remember we heard the story about rudy
giuliani trying to find anyone who would
agree with him while he was wasted the
night of the election
uh in 2020. but we have we have uh next
week we know that a witness that is the
deputy the former deputy press secretary
um that would have
known things that kaylee mcinning knows
or doesn't know or is lying about or
maybe told the truth about can
corroborate some of those those things
and we've seen her as a
kaylee mcinanny
as a piece of evidence where she was
texting people mark meadows and uh in
particular sean hannity i believe
um when they were talking about the 25th
amendment after january 6
to try to get donald trump to [ __ ]
settle down and not try to overthrow our
democracy it seems that's what was
happening so i don't know if
if this witness um and i've already lost
her name here but the deputy press
secretary under kaylee mcinanny
will testify to those tweets and what
she was talking about with the 25th
amendment i i'm sure that she's going to
give testimony on the lead up to the day
of and after january 6. right um i think
so i think so
um so
i i i find it i find it hilarious that
joe rogan
obviously knows
that the
rehabilitation
of trump's image he has that power
because he's done it for others like
alex jones like other jokes right like
other people who are very very dangerous
right he's gonna be like alex jones he
just misunderstood he's a funny guy
he's great you know look look i mean at
the same time while he was being like
here i'll give an example of someone
that i rehabilitated he throws alex
jones under the bus to be like alex
jones had a [ __ ] psychotic break he
had awk he's an alcoholic he has uh
mental health issues like all these
things that would be like
he's like oh well he's right you know
more times than he is wrong it's like
you you won whether those things were
known or not you definitely just put it
out there on the front line to be like
the reason alex jones sounds as crazy as
he is is because he has all these other
issues going on
and so it's i look at that i'm like he
used
he kind of threw him under the bus which
is fine whatever
uh to justify
how
how helpful or how powerful
of a platform that joe rogan has to
rehabilitate
well you know maybe maybe joe rogan
could should consider rehabilitating
another drunk's reputation rudy giuliani
i'm trending at number 16 senator
lindsey graham we know is one of the
five that have been called to testify to
a grand jury in atlanta over their
cooperation or their aim
at trying to steal the election in
georgia by committing fraud um
here's the bloomberg politics
article rudy giuliani senator lindsey
graham and five others have been called
to testify before the grand jury in
atlanta as part of a probe in attempts
by the ex ex president trump and his
supporters to change the result of the
2020 election
we know of the tape we've listened to
the tape
um from the january 6 select the mini
whoa
this is really oh i see no i don't want
to read the article i just want to
retweet the article no i don't want to
read that [ __ ] what are you talking
about
no i wanna we don't we don't read
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] we don't well read
here what are you talking about
i i always tell gabe when he's saying
something that i don't understand like
in technology terms i'm always like
speak hillbilly
speak hillbilly no hillbillies don't
read okay
well i'm just i'm trying to give you
some some news here and and and i'm
still trying to figure out why i can't
log into my account right now man i'm
confused i'm confused i think i think
seth abrams is part of the deep state
and he's trying to i i do honestly
abramson is it abram's is abram's son
if i were a betting man
uh i'm gonna assume
that there were a fair amount of people
possibly that uh that did block me
um
i think it is
i honestly think it's because of his
tweet
i think twitter now
there's a
uh oh yeah he's there because there's
people if you go to the even the um the
announcement of today's show yeah let me
let me see if i can
find that uh there's people um now
attacking even the announcement so he's
he's getting people to it because
because we're doing we did the show and
we we ragged on him to be fair he's a
little upset he he got he got upset that
he got tricked here
um here's and god damn it this [ __ ]
[ __ ] box um so this is this is the theme
for today of course again to extend the
joke
[Laughter]
you did that you did a great a funny
thumbnail and and and this is not gabe's
idea this was my idea yeah
i i i made him seth i made him make this
thumbnail but but you did you did a
great job by putting the daniel dale uh
tweet in the background um but let's
let's look at some of the um
let's look at some of the
the comments here uh elgin says
here king gabe you dropped this
with your crown uh dan says what a weird
day man
um you broke seth gabe cole says
i just robin uh follow the best pro
democracy content on twitter she gives
us a smile thank you oh thank you tara
gives laughs it's funny of course
christopher gives laughs everyone's
laughing it's been entertaining as [ __ ]
um people just don't understand skye
says they just don't get it and
dennis lavin
uh
midas midas mighty aaron uh is watching
she's laughing uh let's see
uh uh wendy is laughing here we go
jeff irman who is jeff herman here i
don't know uh he's a former newspaper
reporter founder publisher
of terp site endless proud dead other
stuff he's got other stuff here uh jeff
says congrats lame as [ __ ] so he must
this this guy must be a set fan yeah
yeah man your tweet your tweet sucks
it really does suck it's uh
like i said i honestly think i don't
know if it's because you're attached to
me or or because you you and yours like
block me to or whatever but i
i don't know man i think i've been
posting that their tweets suck so right
so i probably saw that
and they're attacking i have a hard time
thinking that uh it is i mean i'm still
on my phone for the time being but i do
believe that um right
well here's my guess margie look here
seth blocked her oh poor guy yeah yeah
really he really is gonna like like
minus marky just sent me a message that
says when she searches my name on the
phone it says the term you entered did
not bring up any results please try
again later but you can see my account
and then i asked is that what happens
when you're let me let me let me see
let me see if i can tweet from my
account on my phone
let's see if if i haven't i haven't
tried i've i can send dms i haven't
tried tweeting yet so
well right let me let me see if i can
tweet
um testing
if seth
is out there
still
but
hurt
about
satire
testing
tweet
ah it says it sent my tweet so let's
let's go let's go check out
let's go check out the sea let's see i
can get it to from here boom
let's see
there it is i can tweet from my phone oh
there it is
uh testing if seth is out there still
butt hurt about satire well we're just
testing testing one two so so for some
reason the web the web app is logged us
out all right
i don't know if this is some sort like i
wouldn't it just seems weird that i
would be logged out of the desktop or
like the web version and not on the
phone but you know it's whatever
happens i mean i will have a tweet i'm i
i wrote a tweet i haven't sent it yet
that is addressed specifically to seth
or just some guy named seth that i've
never met
um
poor seth
poor seth
um
weird i don't know
mj says it's not it's not it's only gabe
it's not you tony so obviously they've
mass reported you yeah yeah probably
what's happening so can you tweet from
your account uh let's see send it send a
tweet send the tweet i wrote it here i
wrote a tweet that says it has come to
my attention that a guy named seth is
upset over a parody post
so i guess this might be a good time to
let everyone know that i do not actually
talk to donald trump jr
oh yeah yeah yeah because of the video
do you did you tag that did you post the
video no well yeah yeah i mean i i i did
i did the video
the one from from this weekend right so
here is here's here's gabe's account and
it's up
it's up all right and and even because i
i did a i did something special today
and i broadcast our show
what's let's see let's let's uh one
let's refresh here and see if we can get
the uh
it's there all right
it's good i'm gonna retweet that [ __ ]
uh has anyone has anyone um went and
watched the gabe
uh donald trump jr phone call here's a
seth this is not real let's let's make
sure to give the warning just so
everybody knows we should we should
maybe have a we should we should maybe
have a a flashing thing that just says
not real satire parody sorry seth sorry
seth yeah what a [ __ ] let's listen oh
god what does he want now
the january 6th committee they brought
out a star witness yeah cassidy
hutchinson someone who's at the
epicenter of everything cassidy
hutchinson her name cassidy hutchinson
don't even listen 25 years old so at the
time you know she was in all of the real
conversations there's a lot of photos of
her in meetings with meadows and your
dab she says that after leaving his
january 6 speech donald trump
essentially assaulted
two united states secret service guards
not essentially she did say that she
said that
yeah and it was confirmed by other
secret service guards trump is basically
james more like a toddler having a
tantrum if you know my dad he's a big
dude yeah we can agree on that donald
trump
didn't
didn't steal the presidential limo
because the secret service stopped him
i'm shocked yeah you and peter alexander
one of the people one of the other
officers tony ornato junior i'm gonna
stop you right there okay ornato has
been caught line on multiple occasions
now would you stop bothering me
hell gabe i don't know how many phone
calls you get from this guy but i would
do the same thing that seth did to you
and block him i would block him from
your phone
oh boy have you figured out your account
yet on your side because
i mean i can like i said i could tweet i
could tweet from my phone which is fine
but so well how does that work because
you're the tech guy so how does it work
the web the web app is different than
the phone or something
how is this it's possible it's it's
let's snap out see i'm afraid here's the
thing i am afraid to log out out i'm
afraid to log out of my phone oh because
you won't be able to log back in because
i don't know
if i'll be able to log back in so don't
log out of your phone no i'm not going
to log out so whatever you have another
phone that you can try to log into um no
no
wait wait wait gabe sanchez doesn't have
a burner phone i mean i do i do i figure
i think you're using all the sketches
yeah i do i do i figured that was like
the one that that don jr calls you on
right now that way that way seth seth
doesn't think that it's you know he's
not on to you that it's satire i mean
here's the thing that's what don calls
you on the uh
the iphone or whatever mobile app you're
using on your device it is different
than the web app it's i mean it's still
using the same sign-in protocol it's
still you know looking up and making
sure that you can go in benny loco is
shaming me here she says the web is not
an app yeah yeah yeah well no that's not
true i mean like you can you can have
web apps
um i mean you know
websites as many web apps but
um
but yeah i don't know i i i keep trying
to log in on the desktop and it doesn't
let me so i'm just like i'm not gonna
are you using chrome are you using
corona i was and then i opened safari
and it's still not oh my god it is the
twitter deep state
blocking somebody got a hold of elon and
elon that's probably what it was that's
probably what's
this guy
you know that's a good point maybe
we haven't heard anything from elon in a
while
about twitter maybe that something has
something to do with this maybe it was
elon and seth teaming up though like it
says like hey elon these two guys over
here said you're not gonna buy it and
they're making funny jokes yeah making
funny jokes on the tweety tweets
and they they blocked us maybe that's
what it is i don't know i think it could
be um you know i don't know man this is
weird weird stuff today's today is a
weird day like i said i woke up
and uh we expected we expected though
this morning might be a little bit of a
shock yeah yeah yeah i mean it was
taking off more than the other ones but
i you know i woke up and i certainly
didn't imagine some big account was like
you shouldn't block this guy and it's
like okay whatever i mean if you want to
if you want to do you do you
however i feel like it's you know you're
you got egg on your face and you're
trying to make up for it so what do you
think he tried to like retweet it first
or did he tweet something about it and
then he
and i well you know what i think he did
get duped because someone another big
account said something along the lines
of like i'm i'm glad and i'm pretty sure
you know what i'm talking about was like
i'm glad that uh
that other big accounts uh are still
falling or are have have or do fall for
uh fake releases or something like that
who was this
you mean it's out there on the twitter
version yeah yeah i'm not going to say
who it is i'm not going to say who it is
oh you got to find it yeah yeah you're
going to make me go find this thing but
look i could give you two guesses and
you'll only need one
i i don't know
are you trying to are you trying to say
their name don't say their name
i don't know their name i don't know the
name
uh
uh
it look look i i think i know
i think i know that
i won't say any more i won't say anymore
i'll say it off the air i i will i will
say
i will say that
seth
seth
um did retweet daniel dale's tweet
um i have that proof here
so we're looking here here's daniel
dale's tweet that we showed earlier and
seth has retweeted it here and i
reported that tweet by the way
oh yeah yeah that's me i reported that
tweet yeah yeah oh from the from the
podcast yeah yeah from the pod account
right
right this guy is doing that [ __ ] it's
against the terms of service so
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
say something
oh oh well he look here he's a negative
investor he's an attorney
so he knows the law wow he knows the law
freedom
the law in the law one
uh he's a journalist by the way too um
you know and he's doing all of us a
favor
by making sure to have an unfollow
campaign of a political satirist right
you know what real journalists do
what the real journey he's a trump
biographer oh that's what it is
he's upset because he's a trump
biographer well you got to think he was
going to put this in his new book he was
going to put this in his new book who
are the people that are getting upset oh
my daniel dale he's a trump fact checker
right yeah and seth abramson is a trump
biographer ah
nobody [ __ ] asks for a trump
biography okay
nobody wants to read that
the only the only people who's gonna get
to potentially read that are the you
know trump supporters and then they're
going to get duped because they're going
to find out it's probably critical
or a critique of trump but i don't know
if i would go trump biographer in my bio
to be like that's the thing i want to go
by like my bio by the way is a [ __ ]
joke i talk about being a taco
connoisseur i say hey just you know i'm
a comedian i'm a satirist so stuff on
here
it's going to be funny videos it's going
to be you know these posts i will report
on the news that actually happens like
real important stuff
but i'm going to make fun of dumb [ __ ]
like
seth rogen or joe rogan saying that um
he doesn't want to go on seth rogen do
we mean yeah yeah
yeah but joe rogan's saying he doesn't
want trump on the show and it's like oh
yeah
but trump would 100 get upset about that
right
so
anyway so i think i'm getting an idea of
the account um and actually uh looks
like there's some um breaking news um
from that account even um we got a few
minutes left here there's a new eric
greitens video
um
ron ron has posted this let's let's
watch this video we're
back everybody remembers
when we first rolled on the scene well
i'm no career politician i'm a navy seal
and i'll take dead aim at politics as
usual
by the way they're so cool
it's so cool that they can use a gun to
make something explode that doesn't like
yeah what the [ __ ] i don't do you
remember the one with the marjorie
hookfoot green where she's using the big
rifle yeah yeah you explode the is it a
toyota prius is that what the
it was uh yeah it was a prius yeah right
right right but here here here they are
uh i don't know what he's shooting at
here it's unclear let's see we can see
what he's i don't know it looks like a i
don't know
i don't know what he's shooting at but
let's let watch
everyone also remembers because i fought
for you
they came after me
we're back
i fought for you they came after me is
he talking about the lady that he he
duct taped to the [ __ ] treadmill is
that who he's talking about
might be i i i fought for you
to to give me to perform sexual action
on me with blackmail because i duct
taped you to a treadmill naked and took
pictures of you i fought for you so now
and jesus wiser
stronger still fighting
and this time with an army
of patriots
[Music]
oh my god this is so stupid like this
isn't even
this isn't even
like the other one where he goes into
the house yeah and he's threatening guys
it's a metaphor it's
it's the symbol for this oh he he
understands satire worse than seth does
really yeah honestly but let's let's
watch the rest of this great political
ad i'm sure
it's really boring it's the tic-tac of
this thing is not it's
it takes too long
this is only 47 seconds long and it felt
it's it feels like it's an hour jesus
christ did we not start watching this at
the beginning of the show i don't know
but get better at this
jesus christ
now how do i know that he [ __ ] hit
that thing
what what makes me believe from this
shot watch watch this that i'm uh nope
this is fake this is fake we should get
daniel dale and seth abrams abramson
someone's gonna need to check it i'm
telling you this is not just that is no
evidence
eric greitens eric
i'm gonna get daniel dale all over your
ass
and we're gonna get we're gonna get seth
abramson to have an unfollow campaign
against you uh here really soon really
really soon um you're you're frozen uh
gabe and your face was perfect when you
were frozen oh it was now oh yeah it was
like a uh
and maybe it was just frozen on my end
oh maybe i'm i'm looking for the tweet
that you were trying to um
get to
about because i think i found it but
maybe i didn't maybe i don't know
uh you said someone came to your defense
possibly no no no no no no no this
person didn't come to my defense oh this
person they were butt hurt yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah because you fool yeah
yeah yeah i know you're no no no no
that's why i say i'm not going to say
who it is fool me once yeah shame
because this person has been fooled
before
[Laughter]
they poor poor guy they were upset
they were like other bigger accounts are
still getting fooled by this like it's
not just me
well you know that actually it sounds
like if if bigger accounts still are
getting fooled by this they haven't
caught on that you do saturn and parody
not only that that you use satire and
parody to to post funny um responses
from trump
yeah maybe they're not paying enough
attention yeah and and i can understand
if you get fooled the first time where
you're upset were you upset but then you
get fooled it happens it happens it
happens right we all get fooled you know
we all get fooled we get fooled by
candidates all the time on stuff right
and that's why we got to do our proper
research and vet the candidate to make
sure that they that's right you know
they stand by what they say you rely on
really serious fact checkers to make
sure that satirism if it weren't
this world would be burning down because
there would be so much
twitter would be in trouble this morning
twitter would be in trouble this morning
if they didn't point out that you're a
satirist it would be in real trouble if
they didn't point out that you were
sadders it was it's almost like when
this happens that we don't come on this
show and announce to the entire world on
air live that it's fake yeah and it was
intended to be a joke and right right
we're like oh
joke and we laugh and we say it out loud
you know and it's like
i could give you more warnings but like
we said in the beginning if you put some
sort of uh disclaimer on there to be
like this is parody or this is satire
people like
one
it's it's kind of pretentious i feel
like and belittling to be like hey just
you know before you watch this video uh
it's a it's satire and they're like
you're so dumb you won't get it yeah or
when you're like oh hey guys just so you
know this post is parody then people
might chuckle and laugh
and then they were like well i don't
know why i want to share it and i was
like
right right right like why would you why
would you write a statement about
from trump if it wasn't it didn't appear
to be real this is really [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] and let me tell you something if
you guys want to um
make sure to go follow i am
gabe sanchez today and get a campaign
going dirty sanchez hashtag dirty
sanchez get get him over 50 000
followers today
show seth that his little unfollow
campaign
it's not as good as maybe his political
uh work
and if you're not already following tony
or the podcast i'm sure everyone already
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah but if no one is
following any of the three accounts that
we've just spoken about then follow us
on youtube as well yeah don't forget to
follow and subscribe to youtube so you
can come see how gabe sanchez breaks the
internet every single week
again don't forget to follow us at
tonymichaelspod at the tony michaels and
remember
dirty sanchez follow i am gabe sanchez
today until tomorrow everybody
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
right here on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking